I was 20, but it was the first time I'd ever been to Boston. Kirstie Paul and another student from England had just arrived at Logan Airport. They were about to embark on a new adventure, living in a new city, working with a very important Harvard professor. We stepped off the plane, still a little bit jack lad, very disorientated, going up to this prestigious academic institute that's famous all over the world. Kirstie could think of only one thing to keep her nervousness in check. She had corresponded with a graduate student, Maureen Brinkworth,
and Maureen was to be her supervisor and her mentor. Maureen was also going to be Kirstie's lifeline, someone who would help her navigate not just the halls of Harvard, but the streets of Boston. So we stumbled to the place where she said she was going to be. So she said she would be in Harvard Square opposite a certain restaurant. And so we find it and then we see her and we're just so nervous, but she just, Maureen just had this massive big smile and she just kind of puts you at ease straight away.
And she was like, I'm so excited to meet you. You know, welcome. And then she took us around. And with that, the ice was broken. Over the next few months, Maureen became more than a mentor to Kirstie. She became her friend. But there was something else that was interesting here. This kind of friendship between student and teacher
was also the subject of the research that Kirstie and Maureen were conducting along with Harvard Professor Hunter Gelbach. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In this episode, we're going to talk about the relationships between students and mentors. The bond that Maureen and Kirstie developed made a huge difference in Kirstie's life. Now, I can relate to this. I've had wonderful mentors and teachers, and I know what a difference a great teacher can make. But what about all those students and teachers who don't have that connection?
Today, we're going to tell you about new research that shows that when you don't have that natural spark of chemistry, close relationships between teachers and students can be engineered. And when you do this, it has an incredible positive effect. Stay with us to find out what Maureen, Hunter and Curstie learn together. One lovely autumn day, I was biking along with my daughter and a friend of hers in the bike trailer. And my wife and I had had these sort of ongoing conversations, my daughter's about three at this point, wondering, you know, what actually goes into friendship at age three?
Why has my daughter taken a particular shine to this girl as opposed to some other kid in the class? That's Hunter Gelbach, Maureen and Kirstie's professor at the Harvard Graduate School of Education. And as I'm biking along, I feel like I have figured out the answer to this question because I hear the following conversation. So my daughter says, I like ice cream. The friend says, I like ice cream. My daughter says, I like blueberries. The friend says, me too. I like chocolate ice cream. You can kind of see where this is going. I like chocolate ice cream too.
The friend at this point said, I have a dog. I like my dog. Now it actually gets sort of interesting. So ever since age two, my daughter's been petrified of dogs since there was this little pug that jumped up on her and knocked her over.
So my daughter kind of shifts the category from dog to pets, and so she replies, I have a pet frog, I like my frog. The friend continues, I don't like pizza, I don't like pizza. So now she's just playing line. The friend says,
I don't like blueberries, I don't like blueberries anymore either. So anyway the point being as I'm huffing and puffing on the bike, it seems like what goes into friendships or relationships, and obviously I'm oversimplifying a little bit, is that they have stuff in common, so they go through all these crazy machinations to establish that they are similar to each other in all these, you know, what would seem like kind of superficial ways. Hunter realized that the conversation he had overheard had bigger implications than just friendships between three or all.
Yeah, so let's back up a little bit. So I had had a sort of primary research interest for a long, long time in looking at social perspective taking. So how do teachers and students in particular kind of figure out what each other is thinking and feeling. And so I had a graduate student who was someone I worked with very closely for a long, long time, or Ian Brinkworth, who was really interested in teacher student relationships. And so this seemed like a really natural combination to look
at this sort of how do we do this everyday mind reading and how our students and teachers doing this with each other in the classroom and how good are their relationships. For the experiment he had in mind Hunter created a survey for students and teachers of a ninth grade class. The questionnaire attempted to pinpoint things that teachers and students had in common. The researchers were looking for all kinds of connections. They asked a range of questions. Classroom relevant stuff to outside the classroom stuff, personal to subject matter related sorts of things, several of them kind of speak to people's values. So it was a pretty broad cross section. The researchers selectively shared examples
with the teachers and students that suggested they both had things in common. So a teacher who felt she had nothing in common with a student might discover they both had the same sense of humor. Or a student who felt like his teacher was from Mars might discover they both liked football. When Hunter examined the scores of students who had been induced to see that they had things
in common with their teachers, he found something astonishing. The relationships between teachers and students got stronger, and as they did, students, especially minorities, suddenly started to perform better in class. Then when we look at academic achievement with respect to these black and Latino students, what we find is that when they're in the treatment group, their grades go up by about 0.4 of a letter grade, which translates into over 60% plus reduction in the achievement gap at the school.
That's right, this simple intervention closed 60% of the achievement gap. Educators have been struggling for decades to find ways to close this gap because it's one of the achievement gap. Educators have been struggling for decades to find ways to close this gap because it's one of the most persistent and disturbing disparities in American education. Now, I don't want to imply that this one intervention can fix the whole problem. Hunter's experiment is going to have to be replicated at other schools, with other students and other teachers, but I think the idea is really promising. It's inexpensive, it's easy, and it builds on top of a mountain of other research that finds strong relationships between students and teachers make a difference.
I asked Hunter why black and Latinos might benefit the most from this kind of intervention. So it's a hugely important question. I think my best guess at this point is that when teachers, and you know, for the most part these are white European American teachers, they walk into the classroom, they may not perceive that they would necessarily have much in common with the black and Latino students. You know, that may have implications for how they then end up teaching in the classroom, but as soon as we give them this little anchor and say, hey, you know what, you guys have this in common or you really feel similarly around this,
you share these values, it gives them a hook or an entry point to connect with these students in a productive way as they might have figured out or done on their own with the white and Asian students. There was one twist in the research that Hunter had not anticipated. Students clearly did better academically when their relationships with teachers were strengthened, but when Hunter asked students about whether those relationships were stronger, the students mostly shrugged. And, you know, I'll be honest, I was kind of annoyed that the students didn't feel closer to their teachers as the result of, you know, this intervention that I had put together just for them.
In many ways, it was almost as if strengthening the relationships made a bigger difference to teachers than a DITTA students. And I think, you know, with the sort of connections between teachers and students, there's a default to thinking about how important this is for the students and what they get out of it. But for the teachers or the mentors, you know, I think there's a lot in it too. And I think one of the biggest things I got from my relationship with Maureen. Remember Maureen? That's the woman we told you about earlier in this episode. She helped Hunter conceive the project. She helped design the questionnaires for the ninth grade students, and the bond she formed with Hunter and with new research assistants such as Kirstie
Paul informed the entire direction of the project. But as the research was wrapping up and getting ready to be published, Maureen's own relationship with the entire research team was changing because of a personal tragedy that was unfolding in her own life. I believe it was shortly after her 30th birthday that she got the initial cancer diagnosis. Hunter says that Maureen's strength in the face of this tragedy had a profound effect on him. You know, the level of optimism that she maintained was just, you know, something that I think I will forever strive to emulate and to keep in perspective that when things are going that poorly in life, you can make a really big difference to other people through your attitude. I send her a letter. That's Kostya again, the student who Maureen mentored.
I just kind of wrote down every good memory I have of her and just everything that made me smile about her and how I was so thankful to have had her in my life. Maureen made a significant and positive impact on the research, on the students she mentored, and on her teacher. What I found very powerful is that Maureen's story and her relationship with Hunter and Kirstie and the research they conducted with the ninth grade students all point to the same thing. The relationship between students and teachers is not incidental to how education works, it's central. We were sad to learn that Maureen died in 2014.
She passed away, just as the research she worked on with Hunter and Cursty was being published. Coming up, we're going to change gears. I'm going to place top-what science with Daniel Pink. We look at more research into how relationships between students and teachers can affect education. Back in just a moment. Back now for another round of stopwatch science, I'm Shankar Vaitanthin. And I'm Daniel Pink. Dan is our stopwatch science correspondent. He's also the author of several books about human behavior. On stopwatch science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting
ideas from social science research. I run a stopwatch as Dan speaks and here's the buzzer Dan's going to hear if he hits up against his deadline. Okay. Alright, that's a sign of applause because Dan Pink never hits up against his deadline. Dan, what's the sound of my buzzer? You're going to hear a little throwback sound. It's kind of like a 1970s clock radio buzzer. Take a listen. All right, I love it. As we've just heard, the ties between teachers and students and the
beliefs that teachers and students have about one another can make a big difference in the classroom. On today's edition of Stopwatch Science, we stick with this theme with ideas related to the effects that teachers have on students. Down if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Well, this is a 2014 study that you actually talked about a while back on Morning Edition Shockard. It comes from Friend of the Show Katie Milkman. And here's what she did. She looked at 6,500 professors in 89 disciplines.
She sent emails to these professors from fictitious students asking, can I meet with you to discuss research opportunities? Now, the student names were randomly assigned, so half were men and half were women, and they also signaled ethnicity and race. So some of the students had signaled I'm African American, Hispanic, Indian, Chinese. Did that make a difference in whether the professor responded? And unfortunately, it did. Surprise, surprise, white males got way more responses.
But here's the interesting thing. It was actually more likely to happen at private institutions and public ones, and in higher paying disciplines like engineering rather than comparative literature, and here's the other thing that I found surprising. It didn't matter whether the professor herself was a woman or a man. It was across the board. I find this so interesting, Dan, because of course there's all this other work that suggests that these unconscious biases that the professors had are really held by everyone. And I think studies like this suggest that we all need to be aware of how these biases operate in our lives. Absolutely. Shankar, let's see what you have. Your one minute starts right now. There's been a lot of debate in this country about test scores.
If you can get teachers who boost the test scores of students, does this really tell you anything meaningful about the long term prospects of students, or are these merely teachers who know how to teach to the test? In a recent analysis of more than a million children in a large urban school district, the researchers Rod Chetty and John Friedman at Harvard and Jonah Rockoff at Columbia University find the answer is yes, it makes a huge difference. Chetty and his colleagues find that teachers who have a good track record of improving student test scores have long term effects on those student's lies.
The students are significantly more likely to attend college, to earn more money as young adults, and to live in better neighborhoods. The difference between having a mediocre teacher and one of the better teachers is actually enormous. Chedi and his colleagues find that having such a teacher can change your lifetime earnings by $39,000. And here's the part that's amazing about that statistic, Dan. This is the effect of having one great teacher in one grade in school, one grade, one teacher,
$39,000. Think about the effect of having several great teachers throughout your schooling years. Well, that's something we've always intuitive, but now there's some pretty good data to back that up. I agree, Dad. So let's get to your second study. Your next 60 seconds starts right now. We've talked about students and teachers. Let's bring a third party into the conversation. Parents. Oh, we know that parents matter. How can we get parents to matter more? Great study out of Brown and Harvard about a summer program where kids who had failed courses were trying to get credits so they could pass. The researchers organized the parents into three groups.
One group was a control group, nothing happened to them. One group of parents got a weekly email or text message that had positive information about their student. John was an active participant in class all week, good job. The other third of parents got what was called an improvement message. So Tina missed two homework assignments this week. I know she can do better. Now of the families who got messages, those kids did dramatically better. They were 41% less likely to fail again. Wow. And what was really interesting is that the messages about improvement were far more effective than the messages that just conveyed
positive information. Wow, that's really interesting, Dan. The idea, of course, that positive affirmation can make a big difference to people has been shown in so many other fields as well. Yeah, I think the other thing that's cool about this is that this is an incredibly, incredibly cheap intervention. A text message every week, not a parent-teacher conference, not any kind of big intervention. And I think what it shows is that if we really want to improve the education system, there are some light touch, small wins that we can get that make a huge difference. I love it, Dan.
So let's go to your shanker. You've got one minute. It starts now. When you think about what teachers communicate to students, Dan, and classrooms, we often think about facts, and theories, and explanation. We think about information. But some of the most important things that teachers communicate to students actually happens unconsciously. It's the expectations that a teacher communicates
about whether a student is going to succeed. And now these expectations are enormously powerful in shaping not just how the student behaves, but how the teacher then interacts with the student. In a study of elementary school eight children in Michigan was published in Merrill Palmer Quarterly in 2014, Jacqueline Eccles and Katja Opadjaya find that teachers' beliefs about the potential of children was a very
strong predictor of the children's math test scores throughout elementary school. Now obviously some of the teachers' beliefs are undoubtedly shaped by how these children are actually performing in the classroom, so beliefs don't just come out of thin air, but the insidious thing about this study and other studies, Dan, is that teachers' beliefs and students' behavior are a chicken and egg kind of thing. It isn't just the children's behavior that shapes the beliefs of their teachers, as we saw in the research by Hunter Gelbach, the beliefs of the teachers also shapes the behavior of the children. Go in with high expectations, you'll probably get good results.
That's exactly right, Dan. This has been another edition of Stop What Science. I'm Shankar Vitaanthan. And I'm Daniel Pink. For more Hidden Brain, join us on Facebook and Twitter and listen to my NPR stories on your local public radio station. The Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agargaleson and Maggie Pennman, special thanks this week to Anne Goodenkoff, our actor's Parker and Justin Reinhardt and their older sister,
Mia Reinhardt, who came along to help. I'm Shankar Vidantantham and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.